. We are taking calls at (617) 830-4750 let's
pick
back up with our color from the two five two
area code color from two five two what's your
name?
Where are you calling from?
Okay.
My name is Sharon.
I'm from North Carolina.
Come here.
Yeah, I can hear you fine.
Sharon, what's on your mind?
Okay, great.
Well, um, I've been watching ever since the
whistle blower.
I stay at home and so I've been watching YouTube,
all the news clips about Trump steadily.
I mean everything that they'll probably overdosed
on it, but my concern is that he is so crazy
and deranged at this point, inciting his followers,
uh, to the point that, um, what he just did
last night by overturning stones sentence.
Um, and those four federal prosecutors walking
out, I think.
Okay.
So remember just we want to be clear the sentence,
the sentence hasn't even been handed down
yet.
Nevermind overturned.
We want to be clear that we know what Donald
Trump did was he influenced the recommendation
of seven to nine years to be retracted.
But so far no sentence has been given nor
overturned.
We want to be clear, but I understand the
point you're making.
Yeah.
Okay.
My bad.
I thought he had already been handing down
the seven to nine, but, but anyway, Trump's
getting again directly involved, just like
he did with the Navy seal and all these other
people that he'd decided to step in if we
don't do something now, if somebody doesn't
do something now to take him down a notch
or let him know that he can't get away with
saying, and it's going to have to be somebody
a whole lot smarter than me because I don't
know how you do that to the prison United
States, but I'm just afraid before November
even gets here, that something is going to
happen.
He's going to have his supporters behind him
and you know, his supporters, um, have guns
and it's just, they hate their haters.
They are just crazy enough to, um, do whatever
it takes to make sure that Trump gets what
he wants.
So listen, here's my thought.
You're not wrong generally about the potential
tendency to violence of Trump supporters.
You're not wrong about Donald Trump being
willing to go further and further and further
because why wouldn't he?
He's gotten away with everything so far.
But when you're looking for something to do,
uh, it's mid-February, right?
We at this point are only eight and a half
months from the election there.
The fastest solution is overwhelming.
The vote in November by so much that the voter
suppression can't hand it to Trump, that the
voter purges the meddling that we have to
overwhelm the vote to set.
That's the solution.
And I know a lot of people call in and we're
every day work a day closer and there's folks
still looking for what can we do to get this
under control?
We've just got to overwhelm the vote in November.
That's it.
And I've been saying for years, impeachment
won't get them out.
Get them out.
I get it.
Yeah.
Well, and that's the other thing I was just
going to say is that everybody can do their
part to get somebody they know to slip or
to turn of the blue or to get them.
Um, just it encouraged enough
just to go vote.
Yeah.
And both flips.
Yes.
And if everybody could just get one person
that's thousands more than we [inaudible],
Hey, if everybody gets a non-voter to go vote,
that doubles turnout, right?
I mean, that's not, that's, you shouldn't
underestimate the, uh, the influence of that.
Sharon, a real pleasure.
I appreciate the phone call Sharon from tennis,
from North Carolina.
Rather a hope to hear from you again.